les âmes et bienvenue au canada l'homme
qui vient de passer c'est clément
excellent on a été invitée pendant une
semaine au canada par destination canada
vous expliquera pleinement ce que c'est
assez fou on a un guide qu'elle a avec
nous il y en a des activités prévues
chaque jour on va faire des trucs un peu
what the fuck on va faire des trucs en
pleine nature ça va être que des
activités assez folle là je vous parle
je suis jet lag et pourquoi on a atterri
il y a deux heures et on va déjà tout de
suite maintenant partir faire une
activité
tu es fatigué je pleure est ce que tu
penses que la taille de cette baignoire
et raisonnable tu peux t'asseoir deux
ans et est ce que c'est uniquement un
endroit cool pour rater son arme un nom
j'aimerais me suivent avec la caméra on
va vous faire vivre ça avec nous ça va
être assez oufella on part pour la
première activité c'est du scooter
électrique sur passe muraille ok je me
suis trompé on va visiter le mont royal
en scooter électrique ainsi que les
murales de saint-laurent tout de suite
les amis la peau leur activité sur le
point de commencer j'arrive au magasin
de scooters électriques en fait c'est un
parcours on va se balader on va checker
des murales en fait les murales c'est
des oeuvres de rue et on a beaucoup ici
à montréal donc ça va être une sorte de
petit tour on va aller en maths est
plein ababord la mecque magasins et là
je m'équipe et on va mater toutes ces
oeuvres d'art ensemble
[Musique]
ok on va se balader à l'est de cet
ustensile extrêmement rigolo j'ai mis
une petite caméra embarquée pour vous
puissiez vivre la puissance d'un moteur
électrique de chevaux avec moi j'espère
qu'on va trouver sur des très belles
murales et puis et puis ce qui par
ailleurs
[Musique]
hockey mike première murale c'est une
semaine de travail pour réaliser souci
c'est frédéric qui vient de le dire
frédéric c'est un nouveau youtuber c'est
faux c'est notre guide hachette raide
que nous amener à des sixties dépenses
les deux premiers jours du voyage donc
une semaine pour faire ceci et on dirait
que ça c'est texte qu'il l'a fait
puisque c'est le même visage que les
amants j'en voyais juste là bas qu'est
ce que je fais je m'en vais
[Musique]
il
ok les amis nous sommes à passe on
continue à appuyer pour atteindre le
haut du mont et en fait on aura une vue
sur le centre ville de montréal
quoi de mieux quand tu arrives à
montréal que d'avoir une vue tout de
suite très belle sur montréal
[Musique]
ok on y est on est au sommet du mont
royal de 134 mètres de haut mais vu sur
absolument tous montréal et là-bas 50 km
heure là bas les états unis voilà les
amis on vient de terminer la balade en
scooter électrique c'est très très cool
on a vu de très très belles murale je
suis très content d artiste extrêmement
talentueux autant que le king du dessin
squeeze mais quand même on enchaîne sur
la deuxième activité dernière de cette
journée parce que pour rappeler qu'on a
atterri quand même à midi aujourd'hui
éclat il est 17h et que le jet lag qui
te prend un bon pour cette seconde
activité on va lancer les hd vrai h sur
une cible on aura des vrais h
[Rires]
non ce n'est pas un logo pour un salon
hipsters le barbier de france n'ont fait
partir la fuite ça c'est drôle
[Musique]
ce sont pascal vient de nous expliquer
les règles de sécurité et comment lancer
n'a jamais renoncé au milieu de la sib
lancer parfait avec son retournement
magique du c'est normal c'était vraiment
très beau à tester des célèbres all
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une entaille on a fait une entaille
maker début et non ses plus beaux jours
de ma vie
[Musique]
ça a piqué du père t'a créé ce qui est
dur
ça c'était la scène la plus convaincante
de tous de tout hollywood
[Musique]
ok on sort du sport le plus barbare du
monde c'était fou par la jet lag michael
tu passes ta remarque est belge est là
que ça rend fatigue au nom au nom mais
clément revient on t'aime quand même
clément c'est pas grave bien c'était
très barbare et en fait ça mais derrière
c'est assez sportif de lancer dh pendant
une heure surtout quand tu as un accord
finalement de menthe religieuse là on
rentre on dort et mec
demain jour de programmes de malades à
demain
es tu es primes directes début de la
deuxième journée on est déjà dehors on
est déjà pliée qu'est ce qui se passe le
caté pas en question dans sa chambre
d'hôtel oui deux fois que les amis
aujourd'hui on commence pas en activité
je crois la plus pentue de tous ses
joueurs c'est de la décalade c'est à
dire que c'est une descente en rappel ce
comme des escalades mais inversés mais
tu descends pas de ovi tu descends face
au vide de quoi totalement chez dessus
on est au vieux port c'est une ancienne
tour industriel qui a été aménagé pour
proposer cette activité
on est assez ouf maigre un vrai j'ai un
peu peur envahit j'appréhende un peu on
monte à l'eau monte c'est parti on y va
ok c'est pas tes amis on doit taper 260
marche pour arriver en haut ça fait
soixante mètres de haut un maximum de
sport et de calories brûlées
[Musique]
wahou mec je me shit totalement de
suzanne roy car je suis jamais autant j
2 6 2
[Musique]
repasle intuitif aux débuts des cordes
et quand tu louvre tu peux avancer et
hop ça te stop d'un coup effectué la
ramène à droite très étrange
[Musique]
je sais pas honnêtement je sais pas si
je peux le faire je me suis trop si je
veux si je peux le faire ses courses en
barque avec moi dans ma musique je te
dis je suis un blogueur diouf je suis
trop mal
est ce qu est ce que disent j'ai passé
près de faire quelque chose de trip hop
où je les futures années comme ça c'est
pas finir d'être en vie les amis je me
suis tellement déçu que je recommence
bien voici tout le matériel marche bien
et que j'ai tellement peur je vais chez
elle ça me fera du bien je vais pleurer
tout seul dans un coin là bas à toute
allure
eh les mecs vous aimez je n'ai même pas
l'effet que ça fait c'est terrifiant en
fait c'est juste le gap je pense d'aller
dans le vide qui est difficile
tu vois une fois que tu y étiez c'est
bon
jérémy clément réussisse à un très gros
bonhomme je dois le faire aussi du coup
sinon il va me mener pendant deux
siècles
[Musique]
ok on est droit
ouais
waouh
traduit un truc de malade wahou
mec j'ai envie ailleurs me lie
waouh les gens s'étaient totalement
incroyable avec cette sensation
je n'arrive plus à parler on ne sait
plus quel est mon métier j'ai plus que
je fais dans la vie à les saluer et
bientôt montréal merci j'ai trop bien
fait de deuil à l'est de dire oui
il m'avait prévenu en me disant que
j'allais tout content mais je
n'imaginais pas que je serai à ce point
c'est grâce à vous que je peux vivre ça
[ __ ] que je m'en tiens un truc je sais
pas combien de mètres du sol pour y
sauter et marché à l'horizon ça n'a
aucun sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernière activité de la journée avant
d'aller voir nabil al kelly ou qu'on ne
peut pas venir à montréal sans voir un
ami youtuber c'est pas possible
après étant d'adrénaline et tente une
petite activité plus calme plus posé un
peu de pédalos sur le fleuve saint
laurent
c'est parti mais qu'on vient de signer
une décharge pour un pédalo c'est un peu
violent mais apparemment on va mater une
vidéo qui nous explique comment pédaler
sur un pédalo fred c'est quoi ce délire
c'est un guet-apens qu il assume
totalement ses mecs fait regrettable
pour le plus calmement du monde
au caire les amis le son est dégueulasse
une fois de plus je m'excuse on peut pas
prendre le sony alpha synthèse pourquoi
parce que fred nous a tendu un
guet-apens
en réalité on va aller dans des bateaux
saute mouton c'est des bâtons qui centre
sur les vagues et ceci très très fort
donc on a une corolla à la main et même
bientôt sur le casque rupture song
l'épidémie c'est chaud parce qu'on a eu
une idée de la puissance du truc on ne
sait pas ce qu'on inspire dans la gueule
on a un petit coup de vent sur cinq ont
un style
venu mais ça permettra de pagaille et
docks les rapides ce sont des eaux dans
lesquelles il ya beaucoup de mouvement
sa nouvelle salle est revenue énormément
est une invite de sutton bateau il prend
des coups et nous on est sur ce bateau
ok les amis on s'approche des rapides on
les autres visuels qui a pas mal de
vagues
on est prêt à vous et à
[Musique]
et voilà vous avez toute cette chanson
dans la tête c'est un bon mec
c'était fou que c'était fou [ __ ] mais
qui nous a mis des claques dans la
gueule j'ai jamais fait de saute-mouton
bon j'aurai effet quand je dis terreur
ce soit en voie nabil et on va dans sa
ville mais c'est nous qu'ils mettront
bien on va lui faire une surprise on va
l'emmener faire du jet ski pour aller
voir les feux d'artifice en attendant
repos à l'hôtel c'était top mec [ __ ]
je suis tout ce qu'on en fait tu te
prends vraiment la quantité d'eau d'une
douche entière de 20 minutes mais en
moins de deux secondes et bien d'emmener
bon allez let's go
les amis nous sommes avec je suis
présent qu'avant
labinal qui use à visiter son
appartement habité son chien son chien
est vraiment très très beau ici
attention une photo maintenant il a même
forcé à l'essai sans sac là bas pour
qu'on retourne exprès fille leurs
petites astuces petites astuces et où
les re voir l'appartement de quelqu'un
oublier votre sac chez lui ça marche à
tous les coups c'est fou mais qu on au
festival de juste pour rire côté
bouviala de l'amour partout et nabil
nous a pris une petite poutine spécial
indien
c'est comme le poulet au beurre curie
qu'on croit en france et mais en version
plus compacte chinois c'est énorme c'est
délicieux la tâche en direct live on a
réservé une petite excursion prévoir des
artifices france scooter de mer on veut
plein du ski doo à faire un si doux du
sud où rudy mais ils disent du sidou
seddoo tu es le dernier soir avec fred
il nous quitte demain non
le connaître il s'en va déjà à la dfi
sur un scooter sidou seddoo ainsi vous
[Musique]
où
c'est terminer la balade en amoureux
ça fait plaisir à cette petite balade
oui franchement c'était génial il a
fallu que tu arrives après sept ans de
montréal
je découvre il ya du déclin du jet-ski
regarder devant
ok c'était vraiment cool mec tu as une
très belle ville j'espère que les
activités ozon plus amis ne s'est pas
élevé au ciel vous a plu à les voir la
chaîne die qui nous as abonner à notre
chaîne à nous et je vous fais plein de
bisous a très vite une prochaine vidéo
et look les montants des renvois clément
clément tu dis au revoir m
à bientôt
[Musique]